[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael
rosenbaum how are you today guys hi
how's it going
uh oh i'll be honest with you ryan's
stressed
ryan's stressed you were stressed out
dude i could tell there's a certain
you're so light and carefree you're like
oh that's me yeah
uh commercial uh you're just uh but
you seem a little bit too much on your
plate i'm taking it too much on my plate
uh worried i might have over extended
myself and just over committed
why do you do that i don't know because
uh it sort of started
uh i guess i was in a transitionary
period of my life and i was uh
accepting a lot of i started saying yes
to all the stuff and then uh
pandemic happened and it all kept going
so for you it was more like you know
nice work when you can get it kind of
thing and then all of a sudden you're
like now i'm working too much now i
don't
yeah it's very hard to have that balance
and especially when you're sort of
in a state of flux where you're uh
you're like uh you know i'm doing rose
and bomb show but i'm doing these other
things and now you add a couple more
pieces and now you're like stressed out
you got a relationship you got all this
stuff you got to edit my show
look what takes priority in my show and
um you know you start to go
well you know for instance i got
somebody who's editing my summertime
neighbor video from the album and
he's like hey i got a few other projects
and i go well we're releasing this album
soon so i kind of need this you know
danny's oh i didn't know the
i didn't know the urgency of it so i
guess the thing is i'd say freelance
editors right now
got a lot of [ __ ] going on yeah good for
you we have somehow
and as much sympathy out to everyone who
has not been working
because this is a terrible time but i
think freelance editors have been
in constant demand well hot damn ryan
you know nice work when you can get it
careful what you wish for
also you're young you're eager you're
smart you're capable and i think you're
going to be fine and not yeah i had one
of those nights last night i'm sure
because i think you've had some of them
too anxiety just couldn't sleep
just late just laid there just couldn't
do it well i just got this stuff
i'll give you some my doctor gave me
it's not prescription but it's uh cbd
and um
magnesium and uh boy
i really like it it's just uh it worked
last night so
i feel i feel a little bit tired today
but um you know overall it helps you
sleep magnesium is something you should
it helps you poop too uh we got a great
uh
guest today before we get into that
guest i want to thank everybody of
course for listening
to the podcast and if you're listening
because you love bob saget
or you're interested i hope you hang
around and you subscribe to the podcast
ryan tell me where they could subscribe
uh inside of you pod on twitter inside
of your podcast on instagram and
facebook
those are the handles and you can also
go on on youtube to subscribe
youtube.com inside of you with michael
rosenbaum youtube.com
inside you with michael rosenbaum you
could also go to apple podcast and
please write a review believe it or not
the algorithms and all that [ __ ] it
helps
and this is a a show that just wants to
grow and
i think people get something from it i
know i get something from it
uh it's therapy for me and therapy for
all my friends and all my lovely patrons
who keep this show afloat and
lovely westwood one thank you thank you
ryan thank you
bryce thank you everybody out there um
it's it's freaking
february and i can't believe a year has
almost passed since this whole covet
thing and
uh you know the end is near i think the
the light at the end of the tunnel is
like i could see it it's flickering and
i just want that [ __ ] vaccine
god please i have to take my grandmother
at some point to get vaccinated
good my grandmother just got vaccinated
because michael i got vaccinated both of
them now i could
you still do nothing that's good what do
you mean
well all my friends are getting
vaccinated so hopefully we can play some
polka
i'm like oh that's good i'd love you to
gamble
as the first thing you do after coverage
because she does big bucks she won
i think eight dollars last time she
played better high stakes pokemon
oh man also if you want to join the
lovely patreon group
all my lovely patrons who help support
the show there's a lot of tears and
and and merch boxes i send to different
ones and you get to ask questions to
guests and
that's patreon it's patreon.com inside
of you
and it's a wonderful family and i love
everyone that's a part of it so
thank you but uh also any merch you want
from the inside of your store we've got
everything from mugs and and uh t-shirts
to
tumblers and autographed lex luthor
pictures yeah i got them on here i mean
i figure if you're going to get them you
might as well get them from the source
they've got small little lunch boxes a
bunch of [ __ ] so uh anyway without
further ado why don't we uh get into
bob saget it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
i have a couple questions is my signal
okay because i got real low
um like uh spectrum might have a low
thing i could have them reboot my modem
if you want to wait five or six i think
it's pretty good right now if we go into
a problem then i'll have him do it
all right because and i'm hardwired if
you know what i'm saying you're i all i
got was hard i
couldn't get the last oh my grandmother
are you not
and everything else seems good with my
life yeah yeah
i guess we yeah your life seems good i
saw you on sam ruben you got to be doing
good i mean if you're on sam ruben ktla
5 you
your life couldn't be better he and i go
to the same cleaners
fazios and so we see each other there
and when we go
when i go on there which i do a couple
times a year all we try to talk about is
fazio's cleaners we do like an
ad for fazios and then i get into what
my business is
has business gone up since at fazio's uh
not
really i mean kova doesn't help because
who's you know dry cleaning
it's like where you going what what gala
are you going
he's got more energy i wonder if he does
uh i mean he doesn't probably but
i mean his coffee i think he does red
bull maybe i don't know maybe
i know he's not he's not on stuff he's
not like one of our uh
political officials hey really it's our
job to get up early in the morning and
be 104 and then go serve on the supreme
court
nothing nothing makes me more anxious
than thinking
sometimes you you meet other people that
have obviously different jobs and you're
like i could never do this
i could never be a morning on air person
or even on air
because i know i will f i will okay i
can save
talk but i'll say can i swear on your
podcast right
i think so i think i do but you're not
sure
well you know i try not to f too many
times me too
and and the reason is weird but like i
just had mark maron on
and we couldn't help it i mean and
certain comedians
egg me on because they know i'll do it i
mean if they go there
that's the whole point of like the
aristocrats i didn't want to do that but
they like egg me on
and that's like oh finally i'm popular
in high school
oh i can out f you you know i can out
f you do you know we met uh we didn't
we've known each other for a while and i
always
miss that we are not closer that we
haven't seen each other more now of
course in quarantine we're all sappy
and all oh man bro when this is over
we're gonna go
we're gonna be we're gonna fu we're
gonna
f each other and it's gonna be so much
better
but go ahead what were you saying i'm
sorry well we didn't meet at this
particular place but we have mutual
friends one of your closest friends is
jonathan silverman who we love
love him so much and you guys are
incredibly close yeah he's a great
you know you know since he's you know
he's married now and with a with a kid
it's like when you see each other like
oh you know but you get it it's one of
those things you don't miss a beat but
i know you guys are incredibly close and
we went out one night because you were
friends i believe with this singer that
i love from the 70s 80s
stephen bishop i love stephen bishop oh
we went to that guitar shop it was
wasn't it your connection didn't you
know steven yeah
i know stephen and and i just think he's
you know
on and on that's my
that's my choir boy that a priest
touched voice
oh god you know he's saying that song
from tootsie
something's telling me it might be jews
it might be jews if that's what they're
gonna come back to it always is gonna
come back to that and you put the
you kept the rose in baum i mean you got
a double threat because rose and they
already know you're jewish and then
baum's just
adding berg you know or ring
you know you're you're messed up at
ellis island you're they're gonna come
for you
i think so i think they already was
zagat or zoget
so we don't know my roots really but you
are a jew
i am a jew i'll show you but i'd have to
stand
um but you are a very proud jew and i
remember
i remember all of our conversations and
we might have been partying too it might
have been that time
it was where we were and i know that
your unit is larger than most babies
legs
no wrong you got the wrong guy no no you
were bragging it you were you were you
were talking about it it might have been
that we were going through this cancel
culture now
kind of foe time of
uh of pretending that that we're
gay um and uh well i was but
uh but the point is that that was kind
of
the comedy and now it's just
i don't want to hurt anybody you're
helping people i'm trying to help people
and i don't want to hurt and i don't
even understand why i was that immature
in that
but that's what we did that's what we
would do and i did it with my gay
friends that doesn't help you
that doesn't get you out of it well you
know i think it's funny because you know
we're
obviously i'm i'm flawed as can be and
the more i embrace that and the more i
talk about it
the better i feel it's just like that
makes you non-flawed because you're
working on it and
um i mean do you you i'm sure you see a
shrink or you talk to somebody on
on the uh the zoomer you know i do
because i think that
you know i i come from a family that you
know my my dad doesn't believe in that
stuff he doesn't you know
you know you don't talk about his
feelings and things like that and i just
think he's just very
your dad's british no no he's not
he but you know he was just this guy
that just didn't you know i never saw
him cry and
told which was really emotional where i
lost my sister
um and i know you can relate to that but
i've lost two of them so i'll see you
and i'll raise you you raised me a
sister
right well i'd like to raise her but
she's not gonna look good i mean her
hair is probably gonna leak like
giuliani's you know
see this is how i get through a vehicle
i do go to a shrink
i have for saved my life literally saved
my life
when did you start going i heard you
talk i've heard you talk about this you
talked about it a lot actually of when
you hit that moment where you just
you're you can't do anything you cannot
function you
you get to a point where you're i
couldn't
fill out not that i and i have a tribal
agent but i couldn't
i wanted i like to book myself sometimes
i have pleasure
in knowing that i booked it and
everything's right i'm a control freak
i could not put my name into
american airlines just to type my name
and then i called two friends who'd been
begging me to go to a shrink i had
another string before that
didn't work out right but um and that's
another danger for people but
it i was stunted completely i was this
recently
recently oh this is like ten years ago
eight years ago and it's
because you i know you lost your mom and
dad in the last ten years right
yeah yeah and you also lost your sister
many years ago
or what how many years ago i lost two
sisters that lost one in 1994 from
scleroderma
which is hardening of the skin and it's
similar to covid that your lungs fail
um i usually always say please hold your
laughs till the end
when i talk about that and my other
sister
uh i was like 26 years old and
she died at 34 of her brain aneurysm and
she went through
some real tragic mental health stuff and
and
there were people that didn't help her
she was uh you know
a bit of a victim of people and you were
you wait you were 26 when that happened
yeah and at 26 you'd already had lost
two
sisters no i lost the second one later i
lost the other so that one
i was 26 i don't know how old i was i'm
64. so
uh let's see 20 oh 26 was 84.
so uh i know that because i just posted
my first appearance on the rodney
dangerfield young comedian special it's
the only way i know
any time that's how narcissistic i am as
far as my imdb
goes i mean
you know you talk about this stuff and i
didn't want to get into this stuff right
away i mean i was going to
slowly maybe get into it but like i mean
you're an open book like me and you've
always been sort of open and just like
very generous
started with saying your sister so what
happened to your sister well my sister
pat she's 15. she was born with a
chromosomal disease trisomy
13 i believe it's a rare thing and and
so she was pretty much on her deathbed
from birth and so she's lived in
children's hospital and her children for
her life and she couldn't walk she
couldn't really talk it was just she was
there and this
poor helpless soul and so there was
those those days where you're when you
pray you pray
please like you know you want her to
pass away
in a very uh sort of just
selfless way more of like a just give
her peace and so when it finally
happened after all those years you'd
think
that uh you know it'd be more of a
relief
now for my father she died in his arms
it was
i mean i've never heard my father cry
ever i'm 48 years old and hearing him
so emotional on the phone i broke down i
was like
whoa who what's going on and i was just
like uh you know i love you dad
and he's like i love you too and i was
like what this has never happened it was
just so
it was good it was catholic i
hate to say it but through tragedy uh is
what brings people together
and that i'm really sorry about your
sister
what a horrible life she had to live and
yet
did she she probably had a pretty
unusual attitude about it i would think
well i think she just was you know i
hate to say that she was sort of just
there and she had great
doctors and nurses who loved her so she
wasn't
coherent mentally not really not i mean
she was you know she could she noticed
people recognize people and would
but couldn't really so it's different i
mean you had someone in your life these
two sisters where you're they're a part
of your life and they were
active and all these things and then one
day you get a call and then something
happens
you're like she's gone just like that
right when the brain aneurysm so one was
instant the brain aneurysm i was in
detroit doing stand up and i got a call
and my mom
called me and told me and it happened in
her sleep and we're not sure what
happened we're we'll never be sure
i mean um what do you do though what
what what i mean are you just like
i did two shows that night in detroit
and
i was in shock and now i know better you
don't do the shows
but i did two shows in detroit in the
comedy castle
and i um didn't get any laughs they knew
something was wrong with me i was just
going through a recital of
stand up and i'm a guy who functions on
being present
and when i do stand up since my
beginnings 43 years ago
because i'm 120. i'm a sequoia
but but i i did the shows the only laugh
that i got was for me when i heard in
the club the ice machine dropped like 50
pounds of ice as it was making it
and i said oh there's my sister oh my
god and the audience just stared at me
now today if i had a show must go on
mentality
it depends you know if i don't know i
i might cancel or i might not depending
on who the person is and if i'm able to
function um
but i i don't function well with i was
doing a show
with rebel wilson called super fun night
and i came into player boss and they
said if this goes good we want to have
you on all the time i said well whatever
you guys want i mean i love rebel
and before i go in to do my
the scene i've been working on the one
one thing that was the monologue which
was a tongue twister
um and it was it was complex to
you had to memorize it it wasn't
something you could learn right and
i get a call from the car and my mother
goes bobby i'm in the doctor's office
i've had a um an endoscope
and a what a
at the same time they put the camera
down her throat so the two cameras kind
of met in the middle and wanted to
tickle each other but they couldn't
because she was riddled with tumors
um i don't know why they say riddled it
sounds like she's a batman villain or
something
and um so right before i'm about to go
shoot this scene
she uh says and i've decided to
to not get chemo or radiation i'm going
to go into hospice in
in a couple weeks and i said mom why did
why what and this happened literally
before i was to go to camera
so then i'm sitting in an office i can't
remember one thing
i can't remember anything i had complete
flop sweat
it was and rubble was there trying to
help me and
i i just couldn't do it so what i did
was i joked with the crew
and i ate up about an hour of their time
just riffing about my mom has cancer
and they were laughing but they were
watching like a guy have a breakdown
because what i mean you know if you're
gonna die mom at least let me get my
shots done
you know i had coverage to do and um
and so but other times i guess you don't
i was i was opening for frankie valley
in the four seasons
when his daughter died of a drug
overdose and that's what
jersey boys is based on i was opening
for frankie valley and the four seasons
that night and that's what bobby wrote
uh
jerk jersey boys jerky boys jersey boys
and
frankie and it changed frankie's career
and gave him the full
you know resurgence and appreciation i
was literally opening for him
and i said right before he went on i was
right near him i'm always drawn
to people that are hurting for some
reason i went like what's on the opening
act i'd opened for him once before why
am i standing next to this guy
and uh and i said i'm really sorry i
lost my sister and at that time i had
lost the one that was 26.
at that 30 when i was 26 and she was 34.
and and i said i'm really sorry and he
looked up and he went
thank you thank you bob and then he
opens the door and he sings walk like a
man
and so there is a show must go on
mentality but
how long ago did you lose your sister uh
a couple months ago two months ago
oh my god yeah but back to you it's one
of those things where you say
i couldn't do it i couldn't do it and
then also you get the call and then it's
almost like you go into uh cruise
control it's almost like uh
right maybe that's not the right word
but you sort of kind of go on
it's autopilot autopilot cruise control
autopilot whatever you want
oh it's cruise control that's fine but
you you just
somehow just go and maybe that it's it's
shock and you go through it but i
couldn't imagine having to do
a monologue or a tv show or like you
know i
i think i've prayed before like please
don't die while i'm filming
yeah wait till i'm done it's so selfish
please
have you had it happen no because i just
i don't think i could handle it i don't
think i'm why maybe now
i'm a little the wiring's a little
better but back when i was
you know doing shows early on and i was
young i was so lost and scattered and
hadn't gone to therapy
when you were lex luther on smallville
you had not gone to therapy
no i hadn't gone to therapy and boy did
i need it because i noticed that my
family around me were so highly
dysfunctional
that i'm like oh i'm the normal one but
little did i know
you're not you are getting all this
around you and it's just
inside and it's building and building
and you're you're gonna blow
you know that's why i was drawn to you
because there's a similar energy in a
shark that doesn't stop moving
it's like you have a strength about you
um i was doing two shows
going out of my mind went through a
divorce during
the end of full house and i was still
doing the video show
that's bad divorce is bad have you been
married no
again that's that's not a bad thing i
mean it says locals only on your shirt
so
i think that would mean you just got to
be around well you just got
you just got married again second time
yeah two years ago and
she is uh fantastic she's
upstairs and she said i have a facetime
business meeting
don't come in and this is perfect well
do you
when were you divorced the first time 23
years ago 20 and
was there a long time we were married 14
years and we've been divorced 23 years
and we talk pretty much every day so
you're best friends
well it's we are definitely friends for
the first 10 years
we were not friends it was a lot of pain
and i had guilt i had three young
children when i
split up at four seven and nine were my
three daughters at the time
and i tried the best i could do i was
with people would say oh do you do you
ever see your children i went what do
you ever see your children you know
cause they were with their mom and if
i'm not off doing a movie or something
or i went and directed that year so i
flew my kids to toronto but it would be
every one week mom one week dad
and it would sometimes it would be you
know
thursday to monday with dad i drive them
to school i pick them up you know
you love kids and you drive them um
but now we actually are friends because
we we but that's
it's 23 years later right now yeah but
you got to think like
i think this at a 40 as a 48 year old in
many years before that
but like you know and knowing you a
little bit i i get a sense that
maybe like me you at some point right in
the last
23 years of you said you were single
were there moments where you look in the
mirror and go
you my friend are going to be alone for
the rest of your life
i was positive i had a you've had
girlfriends i know that yeah
and what's the longest running uh
relationship
three years that's a lot i had a two and
a half year
i think um and then it got close to
either ending
or not ending and then when
you know uh i got cheated on i realized
oh this is probably not gonna work
um oh god yeah but you know karma i
don't know
i i that's the worst thing is cheating
is the worst thing because
some people are good at it you know some
people you can you can
just do it not care i don't have that
tony soprano kind of mentality i
i i just i can't lie i can't cover all
the lying
it's enough lying i can't i got too much
to do to have the bandwidth to keep a
live floating with
everyone and everybody knows anyway i
mean people can tell anyway it's like
so silly do you think you're healthier
with someone like if you have someone
consistently and you're not thinking
about other girls or anything
does that help your life with uh sort of
your routine and things
well what's this part about not thinking
about other girls i don't understand
what language you're speaking yeah
that's
that's impossibility but like for
instance you know being
single or dating and in this it's kind
of like a pain in the ass it's kind of
like
it's horrific and in the age of this
quarantine we've been through
coming out of uh we will we will um
i i love my wife so i'm not i'm not
effing this up as they say in the
podcast accessible world for for the
kids today not having this out
for the seven-year-old who's listening
his parents are splitting up and arguing
all the time because they're
they can't get out of the house or they
went and partied in miami and the kid
doesn't know where his parents are and
then they come home
all coked up and partied out because
they didn't
we don't wear an old mask and then dad's
in the hospital
i still don't believe it if this mask oh
my god
inside of you is brought to you by gekko
ryan we've talked about this you rent
your own home you buy your own home i
don't know who else you're gonna call
can't call ghostbusters you gotta call
geico they're not real
i i just think it's the easiest thing in
the world you know they have these
bundling policies that i just find uh
easy do you have time to pay two or
three different insurance
uh i don't think anybody has time nobody
has time no
that's too much so what do you do you
bundle it together with geico that's
right and they can you take care of your
auto policy your whatever
your insurance you could just make it so
easy homeowners renters insurance auto
it's just it's just easy with geico
geico makes it easy to bundle your home
owners or renters insurance along with
your auto policy
one payment come on it's a good thing uh
go to geico folks go to geico.com
get a quote see how much you could save
it's geico
easy visit geico.com today
that's geico.com inside of you is
brought to you by
echelon without echelon i don't know
what i would do
ryan i never had a stationary bike i
never had
a tr uh uh a rower
i would just sit on my couch thinking
should i do push-ups no
i'm going to have that bag of chips but
it's exciting to actually get on a
stationary bike with a screen
and get in front of the mirror and do
some boxing's or stretching or
yoga or sit on the rower and work your
back and get a really strong back
i'm telling you man echelon has changed
my life in so many ways
and uh thank you chris baumack for uh
introducing me to echelon
it's much more affordable than the
others
uh that are out there and you hear
people talking about the others like
and i'm like uh this is great what are
you talking about you're paying this
much money
echelon when it comes to getting in
shape nothing feels as good
as the feeling of accomplishment hitting
your fitness goals
and feeling great about yourself i'm
trying to hit new goals
this year trying to get on the treadmill
at least three or four times a week
at least three every other day do some
boxing do some rowing
you know everything's right there for
you echelon offers the next generation
of connected fitness bikes fitness
mirrors rolling machines and their
echelon stride
smart treadmill no matter what your
favorite fitness activity
echelon gives you a fun and challenging
workout from the comfort of your home
the ex-7s connected bike is built with
performance flexibility and durability
in mind
the ex7s is the bike for competitors at
heart
their world-class instructors will
motivate you with thousands of daily
live and on-demand studio level classes
always available whenever you need them
and unlike their competitors ryan
echelon's affordable for everyone and
one membership lets up to
five family members work out all the
time
you could try echelon fitness equipment
at home for 30
days any echelon fitness equipment 30
days
it's right there go to echelon fit.com
inside of you spell that for me ryan
that's
dot e-c-h-e-l-o-n-fit.com slash inside
of
you echelon fit.com
inside of you inside of you is brought
to you by
helix sleep you know i've had seven
spine surgeries and
if i don't have the most comfortable bed
nobody does
helix sleep is what i'm sleeping on
this company is awesome you take a quiz
it's not hard i could pass it it's like
takes no time at all but just to see how
you sleep and all these things i got
a medium mattress that's what i uh what
i have and
um i i just i feel so
comfortable lying in this freaking bed
and the great thing is if to me
it feels like i'm in a in a hotel you
know those hotel beds ryan
that you just lie down you could just
fall asleep instead and they're like why
can't i get
excuse me where do you sell these beds
um we don't sell these beds
so you always say gosh i can't wait to
sleep in a hotel again
there's just something right about them
they just
on your body you just somehow you're
able to fall asleep
and that's how i feel on a helix bed and
talk about
affordable guys
incredibly affordable incredibly
comfortable you're going to love this
bed
i needed a mattress that could deal with
my back my back issues i didn't want
something that was too hard i wanted
something that was just you know it's
like the porridge
the three bears you gotta get the you
sleep more than
you do anything else in your life that's
true a third of your life is sleep well
maybe more think about it eight hours a
day that's
uh 16 20 that's a third of your life
yeah so you got to get the right badge
you've got to be comfortable
you uh and uh you know with all the
surgeries and stuff i've gone through
mattress after mattress and uh right now
the
the mattress for me is helix helix sleep
has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from soft medium firm
mattresses mattresses great
for cooling you down if you sleep hot
and even a helix plus mattress
for plus size sleepers so if you're
looking for a mattress you take the quiz
you order the mattress that you're
matched to
and the mattress comes right to your
door shipped for free
helix is awesome but you don't need to
take my word for it helix was awarded
the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 and by gq
and wired magazine this is easy folks
you want to sleep right
helix sleep just go to helix sleep
h-e-l-i-x
helix sleep.com inside take their
two-minute sleep quiz
they'll match you to a customized
mattress and they'll give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10-year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights
risk-free at least do that they'll even
pick it up for you
if you don't love it but you will helix
sleep
i look at you as a young kid i mean
obviously you were
you were look at you as a young kid too
which means when this is over we're
going to be
we're going to be happening no but like
when you're young i mean the people
your parents always look at you like
were you an extrovert were they like
this there's something special about bob
bob's
naturally funny so quick he saw this
even when you went to college i read
something where somebody was like
no you're going to do something and
they're like no you need to be in the
entertainment industry
at a young age well you really
researched me
and i i know things about you too i know
all your measurements
um tell me i need a new code
i he had a teacher i was gonna go
pre-med at temple university and i had a
teacher
who passed away who was this great lady
and she said to me don't become a doctor
the joke is i became a comedian and i
said she she saved thousands of lives
as a joke you know because they would
have i would have killed if i either
killed one person or if i had known
someone died on my watch and i couldn't
save them i don't
think i could have survived that and
that that's where i
understand how a doctor not has a holier
than now attitude but an attitude
of um a little bit of
they close himself off emotionally a
little bit because they have to protect
themselves otherwise
you just lose it every time you lose a
patient which is the worst
there must be think of all this [ __ ]
going on right now man there must be so
many people in pain over not being able
to help people
yeah could you have been a doctor that
could you have been a doctor though do
you honestly all joking aside
do you think if you she wouldn't have
said anything and you went to pre-med
do you think you would have been able to
figure it out and become a good doctor
i did pre-med for one semester and i
couldn't do calculus or chemistry
or biology i couldn't do it i just like
i knew potassium was k and iron was fe
you know i held on to that from junior
high i knew a ripple tank
you know i i don't know um i could do
surgery but
not um not through having a degree
but did you think you were gonna be did
you think you were gonna be famous
some people think they're going to be
famous some people you know they have
that feeling of like i honestly did
at the end of college i just remember
i'm going to go and i'm going to make it
i don't know why but i really innately
it wasn't like me bullshitting i just
knew it did you know it
i i didn't what college did you go to
well i went to western kentucky
university in bowling green kentucky
okay and did you study theater i did did
a lot of plays and i just felt like
uh things were starting to go people
were i just felt at some point i was
getting the roles i was getting some
attention and i
and i felt like i finally you know found
what i can do
there was nothing else really and you've
heard the actor's story it's like when i
was
a character i didn't have to be me i
wasn't comfortable i still am not
necessarily comfortable being me so
being someone else was easier
did so right but what about you did you
uh
with me i started writing songs serious
songs like 60 songs and i'd copyright
them and send them to the library of
congress when i was 14. but i started
making eight millimeter movies when i
was nine
so i have 60 hours of eight millimeter
movies
and uh 60 songs where can we hear these
songs
the songs are the worst songs ever come
on
you have 60 there's gotta be one or two
i'm 16. here's one
when i was a boy i wished i would get
older when i was a youth i was gonna be
a soldier but now i look back
now i've got my dream it's a guy a 16
year old talking about like he's been in
vietnam
now more was going on hey i'm 18 years
old i want to live to 90. the
battlefield is cold my past is left
behind me
anybody that writes that should be put
in jail
by the way hang on stop you used the
word youth
that's that's what got me the fact that
you threw in youth
i don't think cause i was so wise at 16.
i missed the draft for vietnam i had
they called my number but i was one year
younger than that number being called so
i would have been in vietnam
and i had a cousin that went and he
ended up getting sprayed by agent orange
and then
his rest of his life was getting
deteriorated from a war
that was wrong i don't know if you heard
but it was wrong yeah i heard that
i heard that from some people but i
don't know i run a radio contest
things just happened to me it wasn't
like i and i never wanted to be
famous i never looked at that i wanted
to be with the best people
i wanted to be with people that i was
attracted to
artistically even though i didn't know i
could be an artist or i didn't know i
would be saying i thought i was
one but i would go sneak in to see don
rickles at the latin casino
in new jersey i saw martin mull
i'm working on a documentary about him
right now and i saw him at the main
point which is where springsteen and
jackson brown used to play in philly
area
out and uh on the main line and um
martin mull was just doing comedy songs
and he was he was kind of a genius you
know and then he did fernwood tonight i
don't know if you remember that
but it was an amazing show we're paying
tribute to him and this you know him
from a lot of other stuff oh i know from
mr mom
yeah mr mom and roseanne yeah of course
sabrina for the youngins yeah and uh the
youngins that are oldens
and uh but it's interesting the
influence is don rickles was a big
influence rodney was a big
influence what tell me about rob here i
want to hear continue but i got to hear
about rodney he's my friend
that's a picture of rodney behind me
with red fox right there oh
two of the best they're having a convo
um
it's really um weird because
i mean and that's on my instagram right
now i posted it uh
and it's it's my set from the young
comedian special on hbo when i was 26 in
and rodney really loved me and i only
had
he i met him in la jolla at the comedy
store and he came in
and he was at la costa to clean up
because he had
uh you know been he's a partier you know
he loved pot i'm gonna smoke it every
day of my life man i don't care who
knows it
and and he uh he comes to the club with
two ladies on each
a lady on each arm and he goes oh man
i saw you on merv griffin man you got a
good head you're jewish you're
you're i had the curse okay you're
jewish all right
how are you i i have to curse you well
i'll i'll do it uh no curse what are you
doing okay yeah
he went you're jewish you're [ __ ] up
you're never going to be happy
you know your mind can't stop working
you don't sleep
and my joke was a new friend you know um
and then he hung out with me all weekend
for three days rodney was everywhere and
he just we he saw himself and me
and always liked to help young comedians
but on this young comedian special i had
three minutes and 45 seconds but i'd
done a 15-minute set
and i introduced him to sam kennison and
i also got sam his first spot at the
comedy store
and so i had a closeness with sam in the
beginning of
after he was done being a faith healer
and wanted to be a comedian
right obviously we see what happened
with him um
and tragically his ending and rodney
i said why did i only have three out
three minutes and 45 seconds because i
was
you know i had a really great set he
went can't help it man i
sam sam crushed man i went well i did
pretty good
and he went sam oh man sam i was like
okay
he always rejected by somebody so he was
oh god he was he was so funny so he
comes in he goes man
i don't know how i'm doing this this is
the comedy store in la jolla he goes no
booze no coke no pot no pills i don't
know how i'm doing
wow that's a comedic sentence without
even effort
was he a lonely guy did you feel like
you have really a good year hey come
hang out with me
well i would hang out with him but he
also married joan
and so i would see her
and um and you know he has two wonderful
kids
uh i don't see brian or talk to brian
occasionally i talked to melanie i owe
her call
melanie roy because rodney's name was
jack roy
and before that it was jacob cohen
and um so he went through a lot of
incarnations to try to survive
well he had a lot of problems with his
father right i read the book and he
always wanted to get approval which i
could understand i always wanted my
father to be proud i always wanted you
know he
wanted love and when i read that it made
me cry because i i thought i just want
to make my dad happy i just want to make
him
you know like me and and when i saw that
other someone else
went through that just you know you get
that feeling like oh
that's kind of like me i get it i get it
did he ever talk to you about that
yeah actually we talked about a lot of
stuff but real quick i just want to ask
you
after you lost your sister recently have
you and your dad
somehow gotten a little closer through
this time yeah yeah yeah
it's been a little bit better over the
last couple years because my grandfather
had alzheimer's so i've talked about
that on the show but he uh
you know he's he's tried he's like you
know i always i don't hold grudges i
really forgive
everyone for you know you know life goes
on and you're like okay what kind of
relationship do i want
i don't i never was really close but hat
you know so
you don't want to set yourself up for
disaster you don't want to get close to
someone who's just going to crush you
every time so you got to stay away from
that there's a
there's a thin line so if you see
potential in someone and they're trying
i always say keep people at arm's length
until you're really sure
that you can open up more and so
he definitely tried i could see some
effort in him that just uh
you know and i think he went through a
lot of stuff and i think sometimes
people think because they're going
through stuff
that they could act a certain way or do
certain things and
um you know i just sort of it was if we
didn't talk about sports there wasn't
really anything else to talk about hey
how about the mets
yeah yeah yeah they suck yeah right all
right i'll talk to you tomorrow
or i'll talk to you next year you do
what a lot of us do is figure out
consider the source what was his
situation so we assumed his father
didn't ever
hug him and well we're getting rid of
that you know
we'll get into that in fact i think i
might be doing your podcast is that true
you are you're we're doing the the
trading podcast
things because i can't stop talking to
you well i love it i mean
to me it's like now it's been years and
last time we were out
we were both uh well actually that was
the stephen bishop night that
you were missing the melo then i was
mellow it was uh it was steven bishop it
was steven bishop
and you know what song i loved is the
one from italy little italy
separate that's the one that lives
collins made famous
yeah i don't know if is it from a movie
i'm not i don't know if it is yeah i
don't think it is
yes it was it won a grammy i believe but
it but but was it
it was i'm looking at the same time you
are because it's such
it's one of the prettiest songs um
i'm just wondering what movie um i'm
looking right now
oh white knights was the most nice yeah
it wasn't
yeah it wasn't right it wasn't a giant
movie but you know
you have no right it's the perfect
breakup song you have no right to ask me
how i feel
you have no right to speak to me so kind
someday
i might find myself looking in your eyes
but for now but for now we'll go on
living separate lives
and that is that's just gut wrenching
because that's about finding love and
then losing love
and then there's still hope that one day
maybe i'll be looking in your eyes
um and it's just there was a time during
um divorce is hard
and especially when there's kids and
there were times during other breakups
where everybody has their music mix you
know and they go to old
standbys or new ones and
that that was one of them i literally
played it on a loop for 24 hours
why do we torture ourselves we do that
i've talked in therapy but that
when we're sad we want to get sadder
we want we want to play save by zero by
the fix a hundred times in a row and
feel
rock bottom and and we it's almost like
like relatability or whatever like you
know when you hear someone else going
through you're like you just want some
kind of connection
yeah exactly and the other thing is
if you're manic oppressive and you
really need medical attention because
you're
god forbid suicidal then you have to
seek help you just have to call your
doctor or call 9-1-1 or whatever
but if if you're doing it the way i did
it because i'm
i was more ocd i still am a bit but
um you know to to
go into the sadness as deep as you can
you know this it's one of the first
rules of therapy and
my acting teacher taught it to me daryl
hickman in 1982
uh the only way to get that to to get
through something
is to to go through it you have to go
through you have to go through it you
have to
feel it so i probably like yourself and
a lot of people
we want to feel things and once you're
sad
if you can go as sad as you can go and
as i get older it's much easier i can
process it
in hours rather than what took me
at 29 years old i was depressed the
whole year
so i didn't want to live at 29 years old
i didn't care if a plane crashed with me
on it
and then i would look around at the
people on the plane and go oh they don't
seem so happy either so
you know did you uh have you ever uh
taken anything have you ever been on an
antidepressant or anything like that
no i've taken stuff to help sleep not
ambien but i was on that for a little
bit but that's the devil's uh pill
the ambien when ambien first came out
i'd be on flights and i'd watch a guy on
ambien
and he'd be moving around like some
slow-motion
weird smeagol type character trying to
get something out of his
carry bag it's not his bag he's moving
streaming
dreaming and moving and eating and
eating and eating and then i realized
i'm
i'm off of this stuff because i'm not
gonna do that
in public or in front of my kids i mean
you just think that with
all the [ __ ] you've been through
especially with all the loss that there
might have been a time in your life
you're like i just need
help i can't feel this low all the time
i need something to you know
did you exercise did you what was it
that you did i exercised a lot
um i'm trying to do better now i
recently lost about
10 pounds because um i i
i took a crap and ejaculated at the same
time
so it was in a five pounds each side
that was a giant load good
good for you it was unbelievable it's
been building up and
my wife has helped me stay for quite
i'll never have prostate cancer he said
knock on knock on wooden nuts
hey let me ask you uh you so you look
very few people have the success you had
now i know you're self-deprecating and
all this [ __ ] and you
i'm self-defecating i stand on my head
in the shower and poop
self-evacuating but you uh i mean you
did a show that was
stood the test the time people remember
that show forever you i mean you've
talked about it ad nauseam and all these
things
do you like on full house and then
america's funny so
i mean you had two shows that lasted
what ten years each
eight eight years each eight years each
nobody has that very few people yeah
they do seinfeld friends
what very few big bang did you enjoy
everybody loves raymond were you always
the guy on set
okay i'll start naming shows first of
all every pilot that doesn't make it to
series but did you
did you do you remember do you look back
and recall it was just all
easy and fun and i liked everybody or
was it like
it was kind of like a family and
sometimes it was dysfunctional i wanted
to kill the kids and i wanted to [ __ ]
smack stamos in this pretty face or was
it all just fun and loving
or was it like sometimes a pain in the
ass um i've always had love for
all people but i dave coulier used to
say about me if you're very very quiet
somewhere in the world you can hear bob
complaining
you know so that's just uh did you
complain about that i complained well
actors as you know complain if they're
working or not working
so you know full house was a gift i i
got fired from a cbs morning show
they fired me and and then i found out
jeff franklin the executive producer
still wanted me to be
danny tanner on full house it's funny
danny canada me is like saying a curse
word and so
oh man i'm gonna danny tanner her um
but i grew into loving it more and more
i was so lucky to get the job
and wanted it so bad to be on a sitcom
wasn't to be famous
i just wanted to act and be on a sitcom
and get do
get laughs and money people get money
and the money is something that really
did a lot that gives you stuff for your
kids and um
and then um the video show happened not
even a year later we did a pilot and
then it
it beat a 60 minutes rerun and then abc
ordered 13.
and it was that when i was writing doing
the voiceovers
like my mother's voice look out you know
that kind of stuff right
want to be mel blanc uh who people don't
know is bugs bunny and
tweety bird every warner brothers
character was just one man this genius
so i copied him and doing voiceovers of
a dog pushing a rock
so it's funny my i didn't always
appreciate it
and now i completely do and understand
what it is
and i like doing family stuff people go
like you know sag
come on be the sagging you know be the
entourage
you know be that [ __ ] and i'm
like you know i okay but this isn't
appropriate to do that at this thing
you know sometimes i've done giant gigs
where i'm performing in front of
10 000 people and that i often
don't go to the very blue depending on
who the audience is
right so you gauge your audience at this
point in your career for many years now
you
you know when you what audience you have
i'm sure in the beginning there were
some audiences like i read them wrong
but now you really know how to read an
audience you're like okay i know right
away and i know if it's my problem
or i've done a couple of things since
february
i did one event which was i did a small
thing for my friend tom papa he did a
thing on a
sound stage and and then i it was like
10 comics and it was kind of like a
largo
in a warehouse in burbank i did 10
minutes and i got out and everybody had
mass
and socially distant far from each other
and then
i went to chappelle's summer camp which
was a dream
that i i wanted to stay longer and they
had to shut it down
but um and that was
pretty amazing i got the camaraderie
that i haven't had in a long time we're
all going through something together
and it was you know it was louis ck and
chris tucker and darnell and michelle
wolf and dave chappelle
and and 400 people in a corn field in
ohio
you know it was really special i really
loved it inside is brought to you by
athletic greens this is a product that i
need i love we all need to to be
healthier
we all need to take you know i went to
the doctor
ryan and i said you know how well how's
my blood work he's like well what kind
of
vitamins do you take you know you're
missing some essentials here and
you're missing this and this and i i
don't want to take a bunch of pills
so i love that athletic greens this
product
i just put it in water mix it up
and i'm ready for my day and i've pretty
much got everything i need
and to me it's simple
and it's awesome
athletic greens can really help guys uh
their their daily all-in-one super
food powder is your nutritional
essential
it really is it's by far the easiest and
most delicious nutritional habit
that you can add to your health your
diet uh
i take it i love it um not only tastes
good but it
i really feel like it's working you know
when you eat like spinach or something
and you're like
i feel healthier i just ate something
it's kind of that feeling you know it's
that
deep body feeling of like i'm doing
something good for you
i'm not eating [ __ ] one
tasty scoop of athletic greens contains
how many vitamins ryan don't tell me yes
uh 10
75 vitamins minerals
and whole food source ingredients
including a multivitamin
multi-mineral probiotic green superfood
blend and more that all work together to
fill the nutritional gaps
in your diet they increase your energy
and focus
and they aid with digestion oh what a
treat
that's what i need supports a healthy
immune system
all without the need to take multiple
products um it's just something that's
so simple
it's it's genius in fact the creator it
was one of those things where he was
taking
all these different things in the
morning these multivitamins and blah
blah because he had you know some if
some issues
and then he said how can i not have to
take all these things and make it just
one one simple thing
and that's what he did and that's what
i'm doing
right now athletic greens is doubling
down on supporting your immune system
during the winter months
they're offering my audience free
one-year supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase if you visit
my link today you'll basically never
have to buy vitamin d
again it's lifestyle friendly whether
you eat keto
uh paleo vegan dairy free or gluten-free
and contains less than one gram of sugar
without compromising on taste athletic
greens continues to obsessively improve
this one holistic formula based on the
latest research producing 53 iterations
over the last decade
and counting they invest in the most
absorbable and natural source of each
ingredient and go above
and beyond in third-party testings to
ensure that we the customers continue to
receive
the highest quality and best daily
nutritional habit
on the planet simply visit
athleticgreens.com
you that's y-o-u and join health experts
athletes and health-conscious go-getters
around the world who make a daily
commitment
to their health every day again simply
visit
athleticgreens.com y o
u and get your free year supply of
vitamin d
and five free travel packs today inside
of you is brought to you by better help
this is one we all need to listen to
folks
we all need help whoever you are i don't
care we all stress some people suck it
in and say
i don't need therapy my dad uh
some people just uh you know they just
they think that they can go along with
life and everything's fine and when
things happen it's all bottled up and
they explode and we all do it in
different ways
emotionally physically and uh you know
i've been going to therapy for
quite some time and i think it is it
makes
a significance significant
uh difference in my life uh
talking to somebody who is objective who
is not
someone you know but i guess you would
get to know
but uh who you could tell everything to
and know that they can't
expose anything and it's private and
there's something great about being able
to say you know i feel this way and
you know ryan doesn't look at me like
i'm sorry you feel that way or
you know you it it's it's really
important and uh i've been going to do
i've been doing therapy for a while and
a lot of my listeners here a lot of the
patrons
you know they write in and about how
they're going to therapy and
how they're doing really well and how
the show's therapy in a lot of ways but
better help is has been there they have
customized
online therapy that offers a video phone
even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera
if you don't want to it's much more and
i'm telling you from experience
much more affordable than in-person
therapy you can start communicating with
your therapist in under
48 hours so if you're going through
something right now all you have to do
is
call them you know get a hold of them
join the millions of people who are
seeing what therapy is really about it
may or may not be for you but it's worth
looking into because
you are the greatest asset uh my good
buddy zach levi told me once he goes
what's your biggest asset i go well my
house
i'm gonna know i go well [ __ ] i don't
know he goes you dumbass
me you guys you you're the asset you're
without you what is it nothing matters
you got to work on you
uh it's time to stop being ashamed of
normal human struggles and start feeling
better because you deserve
to be happy better help
can help you you know i think i feel i
could bring this up to you because most
people probably can't bring it up to you
but
you and i share something in common is
we both
went we both did a long
a show that lasted a long time with
someone who got in trouble i have
someone who is
uh you know allison uh she's you know
she was part of that nexium thing
and she's being tried and she probably
gets sentenced to
prison time and i didn't even know that
yeah she
and i worked with her for seven years
and it was kind of like holy [ __ ] well i
you know and so obviously lori laughlin
you i mean i'm sure you were close with
her was this a big surprise to you
i i i love her i love her and you know
i've been asked it a lot
i'm sure oh you have oh you have yeah
i've gotten whittled down
uh but you're tired you know i just love
her
and so that's uh
i don't know i'd like to i'd like to see
a lot of other people doing time
there's a lot worse people in the world
i i don't know
because we're in such a place where
no matter what i say i'm screwed you
know
and and i just love her and then
so that's that's where i am on that but
i know more people than that that have
been canceled
literally cancelled their careers have
been cancelled due to
um you know uh
cancer culture things that had to do
with real serious stuff like
underage girls and stuff like that and
there
you know last year was a lot of
stand-ups just got
and actors i mean look what happened i
mean it was
it's um and a lot of it um
had no court trial but it was like it
was done and done
you know twitter can destroy you you can
destroy yourself on twitter
right i could write a tweet right now
that could literally
shut me down right now it's so easy
isn't that something and i did a joke in
in 1984 on this clip
this on this rodney dangerfield special
and i was 26 years old and i had a joke
and i
i apologized for it on posting on
instagram because they said you can
cancel me for this
and the joke was um i never got to go to
camp cause my mom thought i'd get
embarrassed undressing in front of
little boys but i kind of like it now
and then i would go no that's not true i
like it a lot no that's not true
i'm not a senator so at that time some
senator had been caught with a
minor so that's not a joke i could do
right now
and yet if i tried to do something like
that
i would tee it up for five minutes then
you get you know
a 10 second laugh and then people wince
and then you got to do another three
minutes to dig out of that
so what's the point that's nice but the
point of the joke if you're
smart enough or not even that smart is
that you're getting to the point of the
senator you're almost speaking from them
you're not saying
you would do this you're like you know i
did say
in that joke that i liked getting
undressed in front of little boys now
but then i would say that's not true so
what does it leave you with it leaves
you with something where there are so
many heinous things that have happened
since from the priesthood to boy scouts
who thought the boy scouts would go
through this you know
it's it's just uh you know when your
group leader says tie a slip knot on my
penis jimmy
you know that's not that's not what
you're in there for
um now that could get me canceled
because it's tragic
yeah so i'd like to apologize right now
i what happens is from my point of view
for me
is when i make a dark joke that is about
the worst
thing it's my way there's two options
i either was three i shut up
which would be what i should have done i
make the joke
and then have to explain the context of
it
or i simply do a public service
announcement for
can you believe this is happening and
that this that young people need to be
protected
and what a horrible horrible world we
live in where human beings could do this
to a child and that is a sin against god
that's the meaning of the joke that's
what i'm saying
but you know sarcasm satire
there's so much pain and so many people
have been hurt
it doesn't work anymore it will again
but maybe not on that level not when it
comes to sexual abuse and stuff
not it won't work on that level but
it's like john rickles doing his act
today it it wouldn't be the same because
he
was making fun of every nationality
every shade of skin
every religious person and he still
would do
anti-semitic self-loathing jokes which
is another problem
you know for people but he got out
uh just in time though i wish he was
alive because i was close with him and i
loved him so much but
you know people change times change
and people know what good people are i
think you know a person that professes
uh goodness and you can tell that
they're and they don't look at you
creepy while they're professing it
are basically you know i think noble at
heart i'd like to
think that people are are better than
they're being portrayed right now even
though we do
have horrific things happening on a much
broader level because of the internet
because of the world because
yeah i i when you and i met when you
were doing smallville
i had dial up internet at full house
you know yeah it was dial-up and i would
go into chat rooms on aol
i remember going to the sharon tate
house
yeah that's jeff franklin's it's not
it's not the house
they knocked it down and built a new
house right but it seems to have the
same gates
that were on once in once upon a time in
hollywood quentin tarantino's movie
right
where you can go to the left and go up
into that house or
to the right where the third act happens
in that movie right
it was interesting to see that movie for
me in in some ways because i
uh stamos and jeff franklin threw my
60th birthday party
in jeff's house and uh and with the band
and the beach boys played you know
mike love and a bunch of the guys and
bruce johnson
it was really i got to sing with the
band that's my birthday wish cause
you're in a band right
so you you love it right love it i just
love i just love music
that's it me too me too and i i do play
with a bunch of people loreman lear has
a thing at his house used to now we do
it on zoom but we don't really play
norman clear norman creator of every
great show
norman larry you still you talk to a
friend of mine oh my gosh
whatever i am and he is everything you'd
want him to be
at 98 and he does three shows in
production
he said he had to sign a three-year
contract when he was 97
so that means he has to re-up when he's
100.
that's what we should strive to do
that's what you need to do is live that
long
well i think i just want to i always say
it it sounds so
whatever but when you when you're 80 or
whatever however you live and you're on
your deathbed you say
did i live the life i wanted to live am
i proud of the life i lived
was i really myself did i find who i was
what my you know destiny what
fate was did i help other people i hope
that when that time
comes i could really say because that's
it really you don't want to be 80 and go
god man i
i was just a [ __ ] up who was i doing
this all for who was i
what was i wasting no you don't you
don't want to do that and
and you're already way past that you're
you know you're
very self-aware and you're very honest
and your podcast helps people and people
that are listening right now
there's no fake in this there's no phone
in this in
you know this is being in every moment
so it's a combination of broadcasting
and
therapy as you said it's therapy for you
i've caught up on all your stuff just
like you were forced to catch up
well what about talk about your podcast
because i'm going to be on your podcast
this is a good time
how long have you been doing it very
soon i've been doing i'm a newbie so
i've been doing it
for um since february or march
so i'm in my almost 70th episode i think
and it's um bob saget's here for you
some people call it here for you but
there's another podcast called here
so don't go to that one no but you can
it's probably good
but um mark maron was funny he was this
is
wtf you know and he was saying to me
what is this here for you are you
telling people you're there for them
and why would you do that i'm like no
but i just i it came out before the
pandemic before
quarantine i titled it because
i was out doing stand-up and i was
feeling that people are
separated they're just there's so much
animosity in my audience
and my job is to
bring them together and have them all
have a good laugh
no matter what political party religion
or race
and and just get out of and
actually here we go i'm talking to
norman lear my obi-wan kenobi but my
friend
and i would i said to him once um
you know i get to take people out of
their lives
for however long my show is you know 90
minutes
exactly that's there with me and i get
to take them out he goes no
no you bring them into their lives
it's like thank you take them thank you
norman yeah
i love that hey that means that means
that you bring them into the moment
and and yeah then that and that's what
this is so i started the podcast
and i call people sometimes i just have
them call a number on my podcast thing
whether it's apple or spotify you know
it's same as you yeah
you're on stitcher snatcher clitzer
snatcher and i think i cursed just
because it it's
during like a thoughtful moment i'll
just throw some odd
things yeah that's what i do i don't
feel comfortable i'm like i'm being
really sincere and vulnerable
i eat [ __ ] i'm constipated
like that's all right dude stay in the
[ __ ] moment
so bob sag it's here for you it's really
about chlamydia
it's really about plea please listen
he's he's such a fun guy to listen to
and talk to as you as you can hear today
and very honest and open and
uh i know you guys are gonna like it um
i have really quick these are this is uh
rapid fire bob saget [ __ ] talking with
bob saget here we go these are from fans
of my patreon
uh mark a says were you surprised that
you weren't asked to appear and how
i met the how i met your mother thing
the reboot well here's a little surprise
for you
i was in the very last episode uh
dancing at the wedding and i was removed
because it should have been an hour
episode and it was only a half hour so
they had to
cut it off they call me shoe leather
when i appear as a cameo and something
they just trim it out
but i also narrated the last episode on
the dvd
set where and i had josh radnor on my
podcast who played ted mosby
and i'm the older ted and i went why
can't josh beat ted
and they went no no you're he's i said
he's drink he drank and smoked for 20
years
so you wanted to make him me an older
dude that
drank and smoked i didn't do a past
tense
anyway uh it was interesting to
do that show and he narrated the last
episode which people got
a little ruffled about but i i loved it
i thought
those carter and craig and pam fryman
they're brilliant
they made a lovely show that was too
long an answer for that
that's all right we can make the next
one shorter jennifer s
how hard was keeping the secret of being
on the mass center for your family and
friends
it was difficult it was horrific i
signed at nda
they signed an nda my wife my oldest
daughter
my middle daughter i didn't sign an nda
because she barely listens what we say
to her while we're
talking to her uh you know she's like oh
daddy have fun
i hear you're doing a show and it's like
but yeah but honey
you can't tell anybody okay i love you
you know
but it was i had a a shirt
that said don't talk to me on it that
they give you a zip up hoodie
and i had on a mask and a visor that's
how i would fly now also and have
and uh it was quite quite difficult my
wife just would call me squiggly
and it would say we'd be on the set
think i got squiggly walking squiggly's
walking and i don't know who other
people are
i don't know who jellyfish or broccoli
is it was an acid trip i never saw
anything out of this
this giant helmet and then i would look
over and see a i don't know
mushroom i'm like where the hell am i
steph a between you got to answer this
honestly between candace jody and the
olsen twins which are the kids you get
along with best
whoever i was with at the moment just
like my own kids
i'm close very close with candace always
was since we did the pilot
jody used to sleep over my house and
play with my daughter
aubrey my oldest ashley and mary kate
i love so much and when i'm in new york
or when they're here when we can we see
each other
so i can't there's no favorite it's just
like picking your own
kid favorite but they're all friends
it's not like they're kids right
but jody was probably more like a kid to
me
then ashley mary kate are more like
friends because i kind of got
the whole thing of everything they're
about and
candace is a friend and she they've all
been there for me
there was a they've been all been there
for me in a big way
when i've gone through hard stuff that's
beautiful lisa h saw you uh doing
stand-up twice question statement in
regards to your stand up i love when you
break out your guitar and sing along
during your live show do you prefer
the improv singing guitar playing or
just the regular bits and jokes
i really love being a new dancer the
most
but i no one comes to that show so
i like um sometimes when i have the
guitar on i will be nude but they can't
tell that i'm
you know that i'm out but um i love all
parts of it i kind of kept the structure
of
my stand up but i'm going to change it
more i think on my next special when i'm
allowed to do one i'm not going to do a
socially distant special but
i really love stand up a lot i get that
muscle
and that's jokes and improv and stories
and the improv is like jazz you know you
just go you just like it's like when
you're playing with your band and you
just go
and then uh the music stuff i've written
some new comedy songs that i think are
the best that i
ever wrote so um and they're funny and
they're poignant
i hope so i'm i'm happy with with
i love i love the whole thing that's why
it's a package you know how important
your package is
uh henry yes your stand-up persona is
much different than your full house
persona you've heard this question but
what is the most interesting comment
you've received from a fan who was
caught off guard by that
um it actually happened on a special i
did um
called 0-60 um
it was really interesting
because i'm kind of at this place of
embracing the father image because
you know obviously you're on a sitcom
you're on a show lex luthor's
not you you know it's an evil bastard
you're a thoughtful caring guy trying to
figure life out that's
kind of the opposite i don't think
people think if you're doing eight years
or something that you are that person
which is
really weird um but i am part that so
kind of what's happened for me
is um there's a blend of being
incredibly considerate about the younger
generation and the older uh and also
loving to be irreverent and say things
that are like what that did he say that
oh god that or just they laugh because
it's fast i try to do things
i like fast humor too sometimes but
i did a thing at the end of this special
0-60
and someone they're applauding someone
goes we love you bob i go thank you i
love you too
this is in the special we put it in and
some guy goes we need you bob
and that just stopped me it stopped me
because it's like a sense of purpose
and and i went well as long as you need
me
i'll be there it was kind of a batman
statement you know it was like
wow you know the michael keaton mantra
of batman
and when i said that they just started
to applaud
and it was so moving for all for for me
that i know it was moving for them
because i could see them moving
they were leaving but um but it's really
that is when people say oh my fans i
love my fans
it's just i don't even call them fans i
call it
people that get what i do when i'm
performing
and appreciate it or i made them feel
good so i don't look at things as being
famous or having
fans or being a celebrity all those are
like
disgusting words to me right unless
they're done right
and there's a big check but otherwise
you know it's just nice
to have that exchange with an audience
no matter what you do as a performer
emily asked what's your reaction or what
was your reaction when they decided to
bring back full house on netflix
oh this will be the first short answer
for you um i i actually
was not surprised because john stamos
and jeff franklin have been trying for
years and um
i i just thought this this will be
interesting because everything else was
getting rebooted
and people want that they want that
familiar feeling again
um and i thought they did a really nice
job and netflix did a great job
launching it it was on six years but
when i first found out i was um i was
happy
i would get to play with everybody and
we weren't there all the time
john dave laurie and i would do like
three or four
episodes a season that's how it worked
maisha says do you have any stories from
uh working with richard pryor critical
condition what was that like
i have a lot um the fun one is
that there was a uh a body
being wheeled past us because richard
was pretending he was a doctor
in a hospital near uh he escaped from
rutgers island
and he washes ashore at a hospital
pretends he's a doctor
to be you know to not get arrested
he doesn't know anything about medicine
and i'm a young doctor so they wield
this body by us
and it's an actor covered in water and
he's dead
and richard i was supposed to say a few
lines i was supposed to say like
oh they found him in the drink after the
storm couldn't get the water out of his
lungs it went on one sentence too long
and the director was michael apted an
amazing director and a
beautiful guy right so we had 40 takes
because i couldn't say it to richard
because it's and it's a lot of extras
around and i
looked at the and some of the major cast
in the thing and i'm
looking into richard's face and i'm
telling him because he says what
happened to this guy and i
he's lost him in the drink you know his
lungs are full of water or something
and every time i'm it hit me
i just didn't stay in character at that
moment and realized
holy [ __ ] you're you're talking to
richard pryor and
and his face just made me laugh
i couldn't help it because he was so
earnest you know that sweet face that he
would make
yeah what happened to that guy yeah
yeah that's a good impression i didn't
really try to do that i just but i could
see it i could feel like what he does
that we love so much that innocent like
and oh wait i i can't do an impression
of him it's funny because dave coulier
who was on full house was him is an
amazing impressionist
and in that movie critical condition
richard wouldn't go in to do the tv
friendly version and take out the curse
words and they couldn't they really
wanted
a black actor to be to do it but nobody
did a better impression of richard than
dave coulier
and this french canadian kid from
detroit so they brought david and dave
looped richard's lines for the tv
version oh my god all right this is very
good this is the final question but it's
not even a question
that was my short answer i love that oh
my god anything richard pryor
lee anne p just wants to say love your
podcast it was great talking to you on
the phone
you were really there for your listeners
and made my day a lot better by just
talking to me thank you for that i
really appreciate you you're a true
mensch
that's really sweet i remember her um
yeah people are as you say about your
podcast they're looking for some solace
and it's you know you it was the days of
free radio where you'd go and you listen
to talk radio and people would
call in and say i'm upset about this and
it still exists you'll have someone
and you know they'll have a hundred
thousand listeners if they're doing okay
but with this you can wind up with
hundreds of thousands or millions of
people
and you look at joe rogan that's an
empire where it's
and that's that's kind of the size of
the johnny carson audience
but you know you know it's it's the
whole country
these podcasts have really helped a lot
of people so
um i'm not doing it some people are
doing it oh i can't shoot my shows so
i'm or i can't make my movie right now
so i'm gonna do a podcast
and they do it for a few months and then
oh i'm gonna stop doing it
because i'm gonna go shoot this movie if
i have a thing i'm planning to direct if
i'm out directing my board
is coming with me my podcast board's
going i'm not going to not do this
right this is um really special to me i
know yours
is you're wonderful on yours ah thank
you i do i fell in love with it at first
i didn't know really why i was doing it
and then all of a sudden you start to
realize it it not only helps you but
it's helping other people and it just
became it definitely has become a
passion and i didn't expect it and
that's it's funny how the hand of fate
kind of takes you sometimes you know
you know and that's what i've learned in
therapy uh
in therapy therapy um which i say twice
it's an ocd thing but uh charlie babbitt
burnt the toast but
i i my therapist taught me something
really smart
and he said what's the thing that you
think you do best in your life
i said well i'd like to think it's being
a dad
he said well take everything else that
you do in your life and bring it up to
that level somehow put that much love
and attention and compassion
and passion into into all different
kinds of work and i think you'll agree
with me that doing a podcast doing a
broadcast doing a show
it could be free radio it could be a
television show
is we need it we need it
it's an exchange program but it i know
it does a lot for me personally and it
brings up your higher self
and you then the rest of your day it's
like a tent pole for your day
and i'll go to dinner and i'll i'll say
to my wife i'll go to dinner
100 feet away and i'll say to my wife
you know i just had the best
talk with michael rosenbaum i had such a
nice talk
um you're going to want to listen to
that and
that's like saying i just saw a friend
and i
loved being with that friend or you were
on you know
i i was on david letterman last night
and
boy i really had a connection with him
last night and that's unusual and that
felt great
that's the word man connection
absolutely when you can connect to who
you're listening to and
it's just uh it's good all around and it
does give you purpose like i feel like
this gives me purpose
absolutely listen to that you're a
podcast bob saget's here for you it
doesn't
necessarily mean bob's there for you but
he is there it's more proverbial
it's some place to go to listen and
just get away and enjoy and it's it will
become part of you
thank you that was the sweetest plug
i've had
since prison on that note dude i love
you i can't wait to be on your podcast
i can't wait either it's gonna be we're
gonna go nuts we will
crazy's going to happen i i can't i've
got all kinds of things i want to know
from you
uh well you'll i'm sure you you will dig
deep my friend
just be careful be careful i'm
constipated
thank you for allowing me inside of you
my friend bob uh thanks for coming on
thanks for letting me be inside of you i
loved it
just a great guy yeah and he's worth a
lot of money
i mean he's worth that's the important
thing no i said good guy first and he's
worth a lot of money
i mean sometimes you ever go to those
things where it says net worth and
you're like okay they're an exaggeration
but still anybody who
they exaggerate that has more than 20
million dollars he's pretty humble for a
20 million dollar
person yeah
but i i always liked bob he was just
always very genuine and sweet
and smart and even to this day you know
i get texts from him saying you know
uh how you doing or just nice little
notes and
he's a busy guy he doesn't have to do
that but i really respect you bob and
i appreciate you coming on the podcast
and once again if you guys enjoyed
today's episode please uh
please subscribe ryan uh at
uh youtube.com inside of you with
michael rosenbaum that's true
and you can go to the handles and follow
us on inside of your podcast
on facebook and that inside you pod
on twitter and instagram also my band
sunspin
at sunspinband and you can go to
sunspin.com
and get all the merch book us as a band
somebody already booked us in la for a
picnic an outside picnic where we play a
little concert
and you get zooms from us and there's a
lot of fun stuff
um so uh thank you to everybody who
supported the album
my patrons you're the reason i i did an
album
i mean you're a big part of it and you
you got it done so thank you thank you
for coming to stage it
and a real big announcement stage it uh
we will be performing again
february the last saturday uh of the
month i believe it's the 27th of
february 2 p.m and a 6 p.m show
get tickets now at stageit.com you'd
also get them at sunspin.com
and fill it up it's a big family it's a
lot of fun we put covers we play songs
from the album and uh it's just a big
party
so i should probably read the uh lovely
patrons
big shout outs to my patrons i love you
so much thank you this is nancy d this
is mary b
leah asks trisha f sarah v little lisa
yukiko jill e
brian h lauren g nico p robin
s hey jerry w how are you rob at i jason
w
stephen j kristen k amelia o allison l
jess j lucas amraj c joshua d
emily s cjp samantha m jennifer and
stacy l carly h
jen s jennis jeunesse
janelle b carrie b tabitha 272 not to be
confused with
uh time at the 273. i just sent a bunch
of merch boxes too from the patrons and
if you join patreon at patreon.com
inside of you i message you right away
and you support the show even more i
love you
ashley ryan kimberly mike e marissa and
el don supremo dan
jack s slater ramirez beth b santiago
amster f chad w
lianne p roshan rashaan roshan
i always mess it up roshan r ray a maya
p
myeshia c mahdi maddie s kendrick f
ashley e shannon d
matt w belinda and kevin v james r chris
h and new should w
osborne h love you all you're born amy c
dave h samantha s spiderman chase sheila
g
not to be confused with sheila e yes ray
h
alyssa c tabitha t misha h deb a tom
and suzanne b henry s katie f almost
done here oh my god there's a lot there
is a lot these are people who are
of of great importance liliana a
highlander we resumed a few times last
week
michelle k we zoomed marcus
marcus because he can marcus w
hannah b michael s talia m
luke h john s andrew t christie s claire
m liz j laura l
chad b uh rachel e nathan e brandel
taylor k neil a marion and meg kay
welcome to all the new patrons
i love you um i hope you enjoyed the
show today bob was very interesting and
fun did you enjoy it ryan i did
yeah he was fun he was very open uh
thanks for listening i love each and
every one of you
i hope you have a wonderful week and uh
thanks for starting the week
off with uh yours truly from ryan and
myself here in the hollywood hills
thanks for uh allowing me to be inside
of each and every one of you
i love you guys thank you rainy days
[Music]
staring down
[Laughter]
[Music]
be
foreign